vinnie goodwill from yahoo sports is
excited about his lions
not just for dan campbell but brad
holmes as well the gm
i hope he's i hope you're as excited
about them as i am i see you repping
your technical barry
man i sanders fired up about your squad
we let off the show with your squad of
any goodwill
why would you do such a thing this was
not timing about the lions i just picked
this shirt out of a while look
because i wanted to you know pay tribute
to my tecmo boldness
i quit the lions july 27th 1999 the day
that barry sanders quit the lions that
was the day that i quit them
i'm not subjecting myself to 20 years of
this nonsense
i'm not going back you know i didn't
know that
i didn't know that you quit the same
thing
i did but now i'm not judging you i
guess that's how people feel about me
when i say i'm out of state
i assume you were a lions fan man
learn something every day look man july
27 1999 i was a freshman in high school
when barry sanders walked away
that was the only thing as a lions fan
that i thought i was going to take some
joy in was that russian record
because there was no chance they were
going to win a super bowl that went
through all the quarterbacks all the
nonsense bobby ross everything else
and this guy made barry sanders retire i
quit
my dad has been a lions fan his entire
life and my mother makes fun of him
every sunday for subjective ministry
you know when 0116 happened me and my
mom was laughing and my dad was
literally
angered about the lions going on 16. and
i bet you because brad holmes is there
now
you know for obvious reasons i bet you
my dad is right back on the bandwagon
let me ask you this let me ask you just
just one answer you know between between
you and mother goodwill
if you had to just break it down and say
here's the reason
that the detroit lions haven't won
anything in my lifetime
it is the number one reason is what
what's the consistent thing is the ford
family right
whether it's william clay ford senior
who's been long past or
you know martha martha ford and now
sheila fordham
who's the daughter now running the team
that's been the consistent
common thread in this lion's you know
50-plus years of ineptitude they won a
playoff game y'all
30 damn years ago do you know how many
things have happened
between january 5th 1992 and today
and you expect the internet yeah
literally anything
this is a franchise of ineptitude in a
sport where basically you are supposed
to go from 10 and 6
to 6 and 10 just by being competent and
they can't win a playoff game
they can't get a home playoff game the
last one of the last shining moments as
a lions fan i can remember
is sterling sharp in the back of the
damn endzone because somebody forgot to
cover
sterling freaking shirt are y'all
serious are y'all serious
all right uh well cool well that was
that's exactly the way i thought we were
gonna start this conversation
uh let's get to another subject that you
love it's been a lot talk about a lot to
happen
a lot has happened with one kyrie irving
since we last
uh saw you uh since we last talked to
you made his debut
kinda sorta with his big three partners
hardin and durant last night
and um man colin sexton
and the worst offensive team in the nba
cooked the nets
and with passes for defense double
overtime by the way i didn't realize
that was kyrie irving's first time back
in cleveland since he left
like they played a tribute video for him
last night i guess he skips all those
trips for some reason
he's kissing him that was he finally got
his video that was crazy to me last
night
anyway um i did like though vinnie what
i heard
from kyrie as he reflected on his
cleveland lebron experience and what a
process that was
they can't defend anybody although that
preceded james harden
is this problem fixable i don't think
the problem is offense i think they'll
figure out offense they can score
and they can share but can they stop
anybody
oh the problem is on both ends and i'll
tell you why and secondly
it's kyrie's second game back to
cleveland his first game
y'all will remember is the unfortunate
gordon hayward
uh game gordon hayward's first game how
you played in that game
but you haven't played it okay makes
sense but to your larger point
to me you got the best scorer on the
planet and to meet the best player on
the planet and kevin durant
he is what everything should run through
and
harden and kyrie should be passing up
those empty calories
even when they have somebody in front of
them that's saying you know what i can
take this guy but let me make sure that
kevin durant gets the basketball
they have to make that willing sacrifice
i'm very curious
if they have that conversation with
themselves if steve nash has that
conversation with them
because kd is more content to stand to
the side and let them cook
when they got it going he's just that
type of player
are they content to say you know what we
need to get k the ball because he's
better at this
than what we do best which is getting
buckets i don't know if they're inclined
to do that and on the defensive end
deandre jordan is your backline defender
kevin durant is your second
tallest player if i'm the new the
brooklyn nets
i am scouring every single waiver wire
buyout market whatever because
right now they don't have enough to win
if you're getting up 150 to the
cleveland cavaliers not only the worst
offensive team
but the worst shooting team which means
you let them get into a rhythm
and then they lit you up so i'm looking
at philadelphia and joel embiid
and saying if they run into each other
in a meaningful seven game series
and there are no roster constructions
made between now and then
they gonna have some problems that they
can't shoot themselves out of
vinny kyrie said you know he missed his
time
and he came back and he described it as
you know needing a pause and he's
looking forward to being with his
teammates
what did you think of his explanation to
his absence
i didn't really think there was an
explanation and i think there's some
merit to the thought that maybe he
doesn't
owe the public an explanation right when
you decide to take
a pause for your own personal reasons i
think some of the things that
the media or the public at large has
issue with
is not necessarily the trust y'all but
some of the imagery some of the things
that we saw during that pause now
there's no manual to say
when you take a pause how are you
supposed to conduct yourself are you
supposed to sit in a cubby hole
and just think about life like there's
no manual for that
so for you know when people were turned
off when they saw kyrie
you know at the birthday party with no
mess and putting himself in protocol
and then not answering that question
about it
that's going to rub people a little bit
the wrong way and i asked him the
question i said you know towards the end
of it i said hey look
you believe that you represent yourself
to be something bigger and greater
than basketball which means that there's
people in the public
that rely on you and i look at you as an
example of something more than a
basketball player and i asked them to
appeal
to those people as far as explanation i
got a really good answer
but to me it all stems from the level of
communication that he did or didn't have
with his team that you don't tell your
bosses
hey i'm going to be sitting out for a
little while and if
you are the brooklyn nets and you have
built this team around
kevin durant james harden kyrie irving
are you
sure that he won't take another pause
and that's not to say that they don't
that's not to say that they lack empathy
that's not to say anything that they
consider
unacceptable or whatever but if you're
building a team and you can admire him
for all the things that he's doing
off the floor how can you trust him to
be reliable
when it counts for him to be physically
present on the floor i think that's a
tough question for them to answer
but they're so far down the road with
this guy there's nothing that they can
really do
you're reliable i'll say that about you
vinnie goodwill
you're alive i appreciate that
appreciate you man we moved your friday
to thursday
because we lazy and we taking off
tomorrow you show up
and you cook just whenever you're just
not lazy it's always there pause
we're taking the paws yeah that's taking
the pawns look
it's it's been it's been an interesting
week for black folk
we deserve that yes
she's been in a year
400 years we should be on vacation
taking his people
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you